la mobilisation contre la loi sécurité
globale se poursuit en france pour ce
nouveau samedi de manifestation dans la
capitale
un rassemblement était prévu place de la
nation à l'appel de gilet jaune
objectif rallier place de la république
où de nombreux opposants élus étaient
présents je crois que la colère est très
très forte sur les attaques aux libertés
qui sont menées par par par ces
gouvernements et par emmanuel macron et
je crois que emmanuel macouin il son
gouvernement ont peur de cette colère
populaire
c'est un vrai souci quel que soit après
l'aller les raisons pour lesquelles les
gens manifestent mais c'est quand même
pas normal que maintenant on soit
habitué ans dans ce pays à ce que sitôt
qu'on manifeste on soit complètement
encadré par la police
on s'habitue trop dans ce pays à une
dérive autoritaire
lors du trajet entre nation et
république quelques tensions éclatent
avec les forces de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
à l'arrivée du cortège place de la
république le calme revient mais en fin
d'après midi des heurts ont lieu entre
forces de l'ordre et manifestants
[Musique]
les canons à eau sont alors rentrés en
action pour disperser la manifestation
parisienne utilisation aussi des canons
à eau à lyon où des centaines de
personnes ont défilé une mobilisation
durant laquelle des grenades de gaz
lacrymogènes ont été tirés à lille et à
toulouse les opposants à la loi sécurité
globale étaient aussi présents ce samedi
je manifeste parce qu'il n'est pas
possible qu'on instaure un tel
déséquilibre entre la population et les
forces de l'ordre
les forces de l'ordre on sait très bien
qu'il ya eu des violences policières ces
dernières années et que sans la
possibilité de filmer
il y aurait jamais eu aucune affaire qui
serait sorti aucune preuve ce projet de
loi heurte violemment ce principe
constitutionnel contre ce droit de tous
les citoyens d'être informés et d'un de
pouvoir recevoir des informations
quand cette loi empêche les journalistes
les entraves et les criminalisent quand
ils font leur boulot c'est une atteinte
grave au droit à l'information
la mobilisation contre la loi sécurité
globale ne devrait pas faiblir avant le
mois de mars et le passage du texte
devant le sénat